hey guys welcome back to big mood this
week the mood is being single is that
good or is that bad or how do you feel
me finding happiness we are single can
you be happy as a single person I don't
know I think we kind of wanted to dive
into in this episode and like I feel
like in my relationships when I was in
my 20s I it was like are you still in
your 20s early 2000 K yeah like
interject she's up in cusp now yeah I
like interjecting it I feel like my old
environment taught me I had to be in a
relationship so in my early 20s it was
like I cannot be single I must be in a
relationship I must be in love the
concept of being single or happy wasn't
even on my radar so I think girl yeah
I'm in a happy relationship now but I'm
wondering you know what would I have
done differently to enjoy being single
thing well being single alright for me I
think the reason why I keep finding
myself single and I'm 32 almost 33 and
not married is because I haven't made
the personal progress that I need to
make with myself personally I think so I
think it's very important to be single
and to make personal progress and get to
know yourself because if you've been
monogamous your entire life you never
really know who you are if you've never
even spent three months or six months or
something without someone else's
influence on your life so I think I keep
getting these relationships they kind of
don't go well but then that single
period is really necessary for me
because I think I get into co-dependent
relationships yeah so I and I keep I'm
single again because oh wait that was
codependent that wasn't healthy so now I
have to be single again and like figure
out how to be happy or like figure out
who I am so that part of being single is
it like a necessary thing supposed to
have a relationship with yourself and
fall in love with you yeah before you
can yeah you ready for someone else it
for me too I feel like that single and
happy moment was when I really found my
passion and a lot of people don't a lot
of you were really scared to be alone
yeah like they're scared to be with
themselves I never had a problem being
alone but I really didn't have that
happiness in a passion and when I was
alone until I was single like from in my
2526 area of my life and that was a life
changer for me especially a game-changer
in relationships moving forward which
was then to Steve was the next
relationship in it I mean that forever
but yeah it was fine like I started
doing a lot more stand-up again getting
back into like my own craft and like
having fun on my own
and then you know really not worrying
about getting into a relationship unless
that person really enhanced my life yeah
for me I've been in a relationship since
I was 16 I've only had two months of
being single and I'm now 30 so I have
you never really back to back yeah it
literally one month between each
relationship since I was 16 so it was
like Isaac's dad one month of being
single and then the next guy woman the
beams he was doing during those months
you had your child
yeah so have never been alone and yeah
ever huh do you ever like I know you
obviously you're not gonna change it now
but do you regret that like do you feel
like long time yeah I had this sense of
regret and I was guilty for feeling the
sense of regret yeah cuz I it ends up
like I end up feeling guilty because I'm
like well every time I would think that
I'm like well at this point in my life
I'm glad things happen because now I
have Isaac and now I have whatever and
like I'll end up like being okay with my
current life but then I can't help but
think back in like regret not just like
that alone you regret you feel like your
regret makes you not grateful for the
things that you have but really it's
just a this what if yeah it's very
completely separated and I feel guilty
and I don't I don't give myself that
that like it's a gentleness it separated
it doesn't have to be together yeah I
struggled with that for many years and
especially after having Isaac so young
so I was 18 when he was born
and I and so like in my early twenties
like when everyone started turning 21
like all my friends and everyone's going
out and like kissing yeah it was really
hard there's I'm like [ __ ] like I love
my son so much I'm so happy he's in my
life but it is really [ __ ] hard right
now just being a single mom like in that
time yeah and on top of that layering on
the FOMO I'm like now I can experience
what all my peers are experiencing and
it was rough so I I I have never really
given myself until recently like this
past year actually like 2019 was a year
of me discovering myself and having a
relationship with myself
while I'm in a marriage so that's why I
like that you went on that trip by
yourself and I know a lot of people
might be like oh that's weird or oh she
wants out of her marriage like who would
take a vacation by themself it's like
that's literally I forgot you never got
the chance to spend time alone without
like yeah so that was really important
there's nothing wrong with that
I mean if once someone wants to take a
vacation on their own I think it's fine
yeah I think that part of self-discovery
is necessary in order to be able to give
to others to your full potential because
you don't really know how much you have
to give until you like spend that time
with yourself yeah I think the thing I'm
doing now is I ask myself I'm like am i
happy right now and I'm like I think
generally I am excuse me there's still a
lot of things that I'm trying to figure
out like who I am and what I want to be
and what I want my life to look like but
I think chasing happiness is really not
the point it's really like content
you've gotta it's not even about that
either I think it's like you just have
to do things to progress your life
forward and rely on yourself to be like
oh I don't have a husband or something
but my life still progressing I'm still
as your bed still moving forward in my
career I'm still like gaining skills I'm
still working on things like a like I
don't have to worry so much about oh is
this happiness but this is still
progression and that's just a part of
life I'm and now it's like I'm not
thinking about if I'm happy or not some
days I am
some days I'm elated I skip down the
street the other day and I was like wow
I'm happy and then the next day I drank
a bunch of tequila by myself at home and
I cried but I think that's a part of
like me processing all these emotions
that I was previously covering up by
just always having someone next to me
distracting
and then and then like when things are
going wrong you're like well it's this
person's fault you know the kind of
channel that it's not saying you
necessarily blame them
you genuinely believe that that is the
cause and then when there's no nothing
else to cause the pain like all you can
do is focus on yourself yeah and
sometimes that hurts even more yeah
sometimes you can really see like what
was caused by you and not by the other
person alone so yeah look coz now I'll
drink alone sometimes in cry but I know
it has nothing to do with Steve like
it's my own [ __ ] because I've been alone
in that position before and I know the
difference between when a relationship
is not doing well and it's making me
have the actions and when I'm just
having those emotions because of my own
thing bro I drink a lot and I have a
[ __ ] blast you've never gotten drunk
at home by yourself and just dove into
YouTube and listen to old nostalgic
songs yeah like I have the [ __ ] time
of my life yeah well I'll get on over
watching voice tat and I'll just back
what's up you [ __ ] old dude if I get
drunk by myself at home I have the best
time like drunken gaming is so fun like
just talking to people and meeting
people for me because I am a child of
the Internet going online and like
talking to people while drunk is no
different than going to the club it's
it's I get that it really is like I feel
like your relationship is kind of set up
to where you almost have like 50/50 like
because you guys haven't moved in
together so you still have a lot of days
where you're kind of almost living
single but then you actually still have
this relationship at the end of the week
like you spend the weekends together and
stuff like that so how does that feel is
that what you expected to be in a
relationship or no and it's like I spent
so much I'm at the time my early 20s
like I need a relationship I need it I
need it I need it and then I got it and
I got into a relationship with someone
that we both value each other's
independence like I am violently
independent I have never been like a
codependent person at all I'm never
bored I'm always busy I'm always like
occupy I'm the opposite yeah I'm always
bored a very codependent dairy nah I
never had a longing for people because
if I want to hang out with somebody I
just go out there and they do it yeah I
I think while we were talking I was
really digging into myself and
trying to figure out if I wasn't in this
relationship what would I be doing
differently and I think the only thing I
would do differently is I'd be hanging
out with more of my guy friends there
are certain guys that my boyfriend
doesn't know or maybe we had a history
together and I just don't think it's
appropriate to see them yeah so I put
those barriers up in the relationship
but otherwise there's nothing the life
is already kind of like it's the same
yeah he is he is very he's very very
busy I'm very very busy and he's
building up a future for us and I'm
building up a future for us and even
sometimes we see each other developing
skill sets that we know are gonna help
us and help our relationship and like we
intend to grow a business together in
the future and I I love that I love that
so much
and now that I own together yeah now
that I have that thing that I thought
that I needed the relationship I kind of
was able to get that out of my vision
and just focus on myself while being in
a relationship and it's like I had this
person that would just catch me if I
fell and I just never really fell I mean
like I you definitely that like when the
whole July thing happened and I lost my
job you know
he was he was there but the funny thing
is is he wasn't doting he almost didn't
really know what to do but he was just
like if you need me I'm here and I
figured it out myself but I did still
have that strong backbone that I needed
I never got like scared or sad I yeah
and I if I were if he and I were to
break up tomorrow
emotionally I'd be very upset because I
love him very very much he is my partner
in crime when we get together it's like
we recharge our batteries together and
we just sync up you know it's like I
have my other half but when we split up
we're still whole almost yeah that's
exactly how I feel and that's I think
something that comes from you really
knowing yourself in like being alone a
lot of a lot by yourself I think the one
time I actually missed living alone like
when I was with Steve was when we both
were working from home cuz when we first
got together he was still working at
maker and so he would be gone even
though we were living together he'd be
gone the majority of the day and I felt
like you know I had the space to myself
and I'm also just so super independent I
like getting in my own zone I don't like
just someone being there because it kind
of interrupts my flow of consciousness
and I remember like when we started
working both working from home after he
left
working at maker and we were in a
two-bedroom apartment that was one level
and I could hear him cough like I could
hear everything that was going on there
and it made me feel just like crowded
and even though he didn't interrupt like
he's independent - he didn't interrupt
me working just him being there made me
feel like I couldn't express myself -
the way that I had the full extent like
I couldn't just like cry without him
hearing me and wanting to be like how
can we make it better or like sometimes
we'd get into little Tiff's because he
would come in and say good morning and
you know super nice super nice thing to
say but if I'm already in a mood and I'm
like in this mode I just like to deal
with it without having to cater to
someone's feeling right at first and it
would be like we really had to learn how
to communicate through that because it
was like I didn't want to snap at him
for him saying good morning that's like
I realized that that's a [ __ ] thing to
do so I would try to like good morning
like wow holding back all of my anger
that I'm feeling towards this other
thing how long have you guys been dating
at the point when you started we moved
in three months after yeah and with a
kid yeah oh my gosh that's a lot that's
like really soon we had known each other
for almost four years I was three and a
half years and I also knew I was in love
with the guy like I wanted to spend
forever with him but you had things that
you wanted to move in even though you
yeah about yourself that you liked your
own space or you didn't realize until
after you moved in you're like oh I kind
of wish I well it felt like since he was
gone so much of the day it felt like
that the timing really worked out
because by the time he'd come home
I was already ready I'm like I already
got my stuff done so I'm ready to like
spend time with you but when he started
spending all day at home - that's when
it got really tough but now we live in a
two-story place yeah and it's kind of
setups kind of weird where his office is
on the first floor way in the back on a
separate place where he's not even below
me he's like to the side and all
and then diagonals yeah yeah where the
kitchen is the only place that we would
meet in the middle yeah and so he can't
hear me I can't hear him we have to call
each other if we want to communicate
I also decorated the entire top level to
what I would decorate if I lived alone
and it does feel very much like this is
my space that is his space and when
we're ready to spend time with each
other the living room is like a mutual
like that's our space as a couple as a
personal area and that's been working
out really well just like yeah perfectly
dude I cannot see myself living with
anyone for a long time because my last
relationship we were together we were
living together for four years and now
that I have my own apartment like that's
probably one of the best things about me
being single right now is the is the way
that I have my little apartment set up I
got decorated I decorated my own balcony
I like put this faux wood flooring on I
love my balcony and every little rituals
apartment I I feel like it's an oasis
I'm like when you're gonna get rid of
the dogs and let me know the sunset from
Alfea my view is amazing yeah like and I
don't have anyone else's energy in there
like I don't have their [ __ ] all over
the place like I always pick up my cups
I always you know like so that's
probably one of the best things the the
I I do want to date someone but I don't
want them in my space and so but i but I
envision a future where it's like oh
we'll have a house together and I do
look forward to that but right now I
cannot imagine living with someone else
it's so funny because with my ex we were
living together and and then there was a
like the lease was over so then we
wanted to get out of that place so I
ended up getting my own place but I was
like you you can't live with me we can
still be together I guess but you're not
living with me yeah I ended up getting
my own apartment and he would come and
visit and like spend the nights and
stuff and like but I'm like you we can't
live together and that's the guy that I
ended up getting engaged with before
Casey so I'm like if we get married you
need to have your own house and I'll be
in my own house and it's like that's
obviously it wasn't
right now yeah well I guess we were both
too stubborn to like end it or whatever
but yeah I I it's a really interesting
situation in that time even though I was
technically in a relationship I got to
experience kind of living alone even
though I had Isaac and that was awesome
so yeah I am so jealous of you do you
know what what I like to do when I'm by
myself so you can feel that coming now
you don't have to eat that food on a
what on a table about decorating the top
floor of our condo I actually redid the
entire master bedroom and I use a
bedroom article I like thank you I am
absolutely in love with articles
furniture it's this mid-century modern
slash Scandinavian touch his design / in
completely my style the whole bedroom
got remodeled to be this mid-century
boho scan the type of style love it and
I'm in love in love with it it's a
walnut bed and it's the sturdiest piece
of furniture
I have yeah ever owned in my life I just
never I never knew a bed could be like
that and you save up to 30% on
traditional retail prices and my first
movement of my place I was getting cheap
furniture because I was like I need a
coffee table I need a chair yeah and
then it kind of started to it was a
little gets wobbly yeah and then when I
upgraded to an article bed I instantly
thought up graded my quality of life
like that was my favorite part about it
I feel like I feel like an adult
I felt like an adult I'm older get rid
of that Bachelor furniture you want to
impress her but make sure that bedding
or break yeah they're actually able to
keep the prices low by cutting out the
middleman and selling directly to you so
there's no showrooms no salespeople no
retail markups no I got it
you also have 30 days to make up your
mind with simple returns and exchanges
article is offering our listeners $50
off their first purchase of $100 or more
to claim visit article dot-com / big
mood and the discount code will be
automatically applied at check out
that's article com
/ big mood to get $50 off your first
purchase of $100 more more I'm doing it
I just got a house I need to furnish it
I'm doing it 50 voice is a lot anything
but free
well yeah so I remember that one month
after that guy that I just talked about
the world's like you live somewhere else
and I live somewhere else
I had my girlfriend's over all the time
like every weekend for weekends in a row
and we would throw parties and stuff
because I was they even slept over one
time like immediately after the breakup
because first of all this guy would not
let me go and he was like stalking my
house and I got a little scary that's
one reason the other reason was cause
like I was like girls I don't know how
to be alone like can you please like
Isaac's gonna be spending the weekend at
his dad's like I don't know how to be by
myself so I don't think I don't think
that helped you because trying to be
nice it was a crush also I really like
begged I'm like please don't let me tell
you girls young girls you have to spend
those nights alone you have to get
through it or otherwise you're just
gonna always be chasing having some like
the baby in the crib screaming yelling
you have to let him smash otherwise
they're never gonna sleep through the
night you know what I found helped me
through that because when I first when I
first moved to LA it was with my
boyfriend at the time and we were
together for three more years after that
so lived with him for three years my
first three years in LA then when we
broke up I is when I got my own
apartment and the first night I had one
of my best friend's from Santa Barbara
spend the night with me because I was
scared because I hadn't spent a night
alone in yeah ever because I was living
with my parents and then I was living
with him and I was thankful she was
there because there was like this
crackhead that and it'll be funny a
story about this meth had climbed the
palm trees outside of my window he was
like you're the devil to get to our
window but like there's like the palm
tree was far enough away from the window
you
he couldn't get there but Jon we were
cracking up and we were like college
experience at Texas State a lot of yeah
a lot of people on drugs
we were giggling it was fun but after
that night I I was fine without someone
there and what I found really helps me
like
comfortable being alone was making
little details that made it a home and
that's when I think I really got into
nesting and making my environment a home
and not just like somewhere I live so I
the first thing I did was I bought a
bunch of drawer liners that were cute
like vintage looking drawer liners and
it lined all the drawers that were built
into this like old-timey unit it was
like from the silent film era so there
was like built in dressers and I didn't
want to be all nasty so I put those
drawer liners and they were like cute
and floral and then I went and bought a
bunch of towels from Bed Bath & Beyond
it was like brand new and it just little
things that made your parents house feel
like home you can do that that's exactly
what your home I've been doing yeah I
did not realize how important like you
call it nesting yeah yeah you know even
when I was younger and I had my own room
in my parents house it didn't even feel
like my room it felt like a room in my
parents house I didn't I feel like
that's almost a skill making a place
your own home when I when I first got to
LA I lived in a very small apartment and
then when I moved to my one-bedroom I
had this huge one-bedroom and I it's a
nice size yeah a nice for like a single
person and I I didn't want to decorate
it because I was afraid that at any
point like Smosh would go under and I
would lose my job and I'd have to go
back to Virginia I didn't want to have
to deal with putting furniture and
storage or selling is really moving back
or I was like I'll have to get a
roommate so I never decorated I just had
a couch a TV and a gaming computer
because I was like at any moment this
life will be over
and so just last month was the first
time I got a bookshelf I decorated my
vanity oh my shoe rack like all of this
stuff because I was like I'm ready to
make this a home and yeah I haven't even
put wall art up and stuff and this is
the first time I'm like this is my plate
yeah you know you have to mark your
independent somewhere yeah and doing it
in your home is incredibly important
because where else do you mark your
independence yeah like almost nowhere
yes truly like I mean other than maybe
like your body like if you're a person
that gets a lot of tattoos but I I don't
know how else you mark your own
territory because other ways you're just
a piece of the world and if you are a
person kind of what I'm hearing is like
it seems like Nikki and I are like very
very independent
and like you guys have some codependent
tendencies and I think that's a
personality type that you can kind of
break the mold out of yeah but when
you're codependent it's scary to try to
become independent you're just like I
can't do this a lot of times people just
fold and say this is not possible but it
really is yeah I just got like a blend
because like there were moments to where
like during that time I had planned like
okay this New Year's Eve it's always
been my dream I'm gonna see the ball
drop in Times Square like I set that
goal up for myself and that was 2012
going into 2013 and I was like no matter
what I'm going and those girlfriends
they were like yeah we'll all go we'll
make it a girls trip and then eventually
one by one started like dropping out and
then by then Casey and I started dating
and so I was like yeah I'm going to New
York like well the last girl just
dropped out I don't give a [ __ ] I'm
going I'm going by myself like I have to
do this I have to make this happen and
he was like well I don't want you going
alone like it's scary so they hand up
coming with me but I would I really had
that fire any me where I'm like no
matter what I'm doing this even if I had
to do it alone but I didn't end up doing
it alone but yeah I I am kind of I want
to believe that codependency is they
learned or like an environment not
something doing it's definitely I mean
it usually comes from like you like
feelings of abandonment your childhood
so it's definitely learned yeah you can
break it with therapy I because because
I was always independent I never felt
like I was codependent but then I got
into a toxic relationship where it
brought a codependent side out of me
yeah took what I didn't even recognize
myself anymore it was a kind of abusive
relationship and it was kind of got in -
at the same time where like it was first
I got a abusive business relationship
with this manager guy and then I started
dating someone who was the same level of
narcissism that creates codependency or
let that codependent people are
attracted to and so it just weakened me
to this point of like I don't even know
that girl I've I was only that girl for
two years of my life I was never that
girl before I don't know how that
happened but through therapy I broke out
of it again and became myself like
yeah once you understand like where it
comes from or like why yeah happening
it's it's not like static it's not like
forever you're gonna be codependent I
think I think it's just figuring out
things that you love to do by yourself
and just doing them I was doing I'm like
because I'm the only one single right
now you do tennis yeah I don't do that
anymore but I did have a coach for a
little while um I was really enjoying
that but like I've been spending time
reading and that's something that I
haven't been able to do for so long like
when I was younger I was a huge book
reader I was constantly reading and then
there was a this span of time and my
pretty much about most of my 20s where I
could not focus on a book I had really
high anxiety I was just there was just
always something where I just I couldn't
get myself to read a [ __ ] book like
just read a book and now I've been doing
that I've been taking notes while in
reading books it's like I'm not in
school anymore I don't need this but I'm
like reading these books on like
economics and society and philosophy and
all this stuff and I'm like oh I there's
a vocabulary word I don't know I [ __ ]
write this [ __ ] out in a journal and I
write out what the definition of it is
and I'm just spending time with myself
like oh I feel like building my
intellect and like if I was in my last
relationship I wouldn't be doing that I
would be staying in the same place I was
mentally doing the same things I was
mentally on his time and but now and the
same goes for him like whatever he's
spending his time on now like he's
building his intellect he's not worried
about what do I need to do to make sure
she eats dinner tonight yeah you know
like we're able to like actually really
grow ourselves and that's something we
both really needed and when you're like
reading and taking notes and everything
how does that make you feel it feels
really like I'm not thinking about all
the [ __ ] in life like I'm literally
just focused on oh this is a new concept
this is a new thing that I never even
thought of
I discovered this this Italian kind of
like I don't know what you would call it
I guess it's sort of a concept and it's
just like it's it it's called like
spretz a Twitter or something like that
and it it's talking about like it's in
fashion but also just in life it's about
putting forth a whole bunch of effort
thinking about things a lot and doing
your best at it but not showing it so
it's like effortless elegant
and I'm like I love this idea of like
spretz a Torah or whatever and I'm just
like thinking about like oh and I'm like
looking up [ __ ] I'm like oh that's
there's like a men's fashion that has to
do with that but that's also like a
thing in life so like you try your
hardest at work nobody knows that you
spent time extra time to turn in this
project but it just looks like you're
effortlessly smart yeah and not
complaining about it not showing that
you put so much effort into it but it's
just like oh I'm doing everything nicely
and I'm like I love this concept what I
love the most about that is that to me
that's a form of happiness that can
never be taken away from you
yeah that it literally cannot you know
in a relationship you feel this peak of
happiness but it comes and goes
depending on how that person feels about
you if they're having a bad day if
there's someone else that's caught their
eye and then suddenly your happiness is
gone yeah you know it's it's it's
external now while reading a book is
technically some form of external but
that happiness is coming from within
yeah and I think that that's a huge
component of being happy when you're
single is manifesting that happiness on
your own rather than with a person or or
understanding that it's basically all
coming like this thing I don't I don't
know how to fully describe this but I'm
gonna try to so something that I've been
feeling a lot lately is that so maybe I
had a crush for like a little while and
it kind of it like made me really happy
for a little while but then that crush
went away but then what I realized was
like I created that feeling of happiness
and I created that fantasy and I created
all these good feelings that I felt for
him so even if that didn't work out or
if it doesn't work out like really all
of the things that you're creating are
in your own head so even a go song lyric
with she goes like yeah so it's kind of
like even if you loved someone and they
left it's like all of the happiness that
you were feeling that was inside of you
and created by you anyway so just
because they're gone that doesn't mean
that that that happiness is not there
wasn't even really them it was like you
created I I had that epiphany - yeah it
was a little bit tweaked so it was more
like in in
my marriage where there were all these
little things I just like hurts me I'm
like why does he have to do this one
thing or whatever and then it kind of
like a light bulb turned on in my head
were you that's getting an ocean yeah
where I'm like wait it doesn't have to
be like for example it was like taking
out the trash
that's a stupid example would let's just
say that I'm like why didn't you take
all the trash like you said he was gonna
do it whatever I just got up and I did
it myself and I'm like cool now I don't
have to be pissed about this thing and
now I'm happy like this is so stupid
like I could have been happy and like
created that myself were like done it
myself and not place all that weight on
someone else yeah I'm like that's the
epitome moment for me that I was like
this is huge and I told him he got so
happy he's like yeah
stop bitching at every little thing like
stop nagging yes yes there's so many
times that we and I'm not saying this
every single time but a lot of times
where we could control our emotions but
we don't you know to an extent we almost
choose to and it feels like you're
controlling is just like letting go
letting it go or taking the situation to
our own hands or you know deciding to
take the high ground we're separating
from how much you're focusing on
something that's not even real or yeah
there's been so many times where I get
upset or angry over something cuz I'm
bored and I don't have anything else
worried about yeah you know and it and I
am like I I say that was kind of I say
that lightly because there are some
times where something just
environmentally it's just completely out
of your control but then there's also
times where there's situations that are
out of your control but you choose to
shoot the second arrow into yourself and
poison your mind with worry afterwards
and that's something that I I had
something I had something that really
bothered me a few weeks ago and I
watched out of my apartment and I'm
thinking about it thinking about it
thinking about it and I was like whoa
both stop and I told myself don't shoot
the second arrow which was don't take
this thing it's almost like I remember
one time we talked about this tip it's
like these it's like these bullets come
at you and you have to stop them and
decide not to take that bullet like you
have to dodge it like the bullets have
already been fired it's happened and
whether it's a situation in your life
whether it's losing somebody a breakup
unkind word something that's
and then you don't have the example yeah
yeah you don't have to take that bullet
you just just dodge it and walk away
from it it happened it was fired it was
shot but you don't have to be affected
by it and that's kind of something that
I let walk with me all the time and this
day where I walked out of my house and I
was so stressed out I kept telling
myself don't shoot the second arrow
don't take it don't take it don't let it
poison your day and within five minutes
I had completely forgotten I I chose not
to feel that emotion and I completely
forgot about it and I was like I can't
wait for something happen again I was
like [ __ ] the power now yeah like and
and and it's like choosing not to let
someone or something take your happiness
or your independence away from you and
just moving on with your day like if you
if you can't yeah I think another thing
that gets to people that I think you
brought up the opposite of it which is
like finding an activity or something
that you do just for yourself that like
no one has to know that you put in that
extra effort yeah or like it's just
something that you feel fulfilled by and
no one else has to know about I think on
the other on the other end of the
spectrum of that people are getting
really depressed when they start
comparing themselves to other people
like because we are in such a culture
that shares every little thing that
we're doing it's like sometimes you can
be alone and single and like you you
suddenly start to see all of the happy
couples where like before mine's me I
wrote on Instagram so like I posted for
Valentine's Day and like I posted
something about like me and Kasey but
then at the end I said like love is such
a beautiful thing to celebrate so even
if you have no one to celebrate with
like just celebrate self-love like
that's important too and then there were
people like sending me messages saying
like that really hit me I think you I
really needed to hear that and like I
just and then like people were venting
and just saying like you know seeing all
these couples like on Banta Valentine's
Day is really hard for me but you
reminded me you reminded me that it's
important to also just love me and not
need to depend on someone else so I'm
like yeah dude I'm true that's totally
that's the saint yeah definitely like
the same concept of like it's like when
you think of a color like there's that
exercise where it's like think of the
color green and then all of a sudden
everything you see around you it's just
the good the green things
out more so when you're thinking about
your lack of like happiness in a
relationship and you just start seeing
like happy couples everywhere and then
you get really sad about it where you
think that that thing is missing rather
than that like that thing would just
enhance when you're ready or that's just
enough and your your time line right now
I thought it was interesting too when
something like now I talk about my
relationship with Steve and I think we
have a great relationship and I am so
grateful for it but it's not something
that I think about all the time it's
just when we're talking about
relationships I'll talk about it because
I've definitely been in unhealthy
relationships and I've been in this one
I don't think about it as like this I
never thought of it as this thing that I
really needed so it doesn't really cross
my mind until someone says something
like why do you have to talk about your
relationship all the time or like why do
you like well you know when there's like
a comment like that I'm like wow I
didn't even think about that but that
person is in a place where they don't
have that and so they're just seeing
that we're layering yeah where I've had
that before career-wise where I see
people like just killing it crushing it
in their careers your sitcom so much
yeah or they're just booking it just
seems like they're booking thing after
thing after thing and I just started
getting mad at them like I start getting
frustrated like why do they always have
to be posting about their shows that
they book because I was mad that I
didn't have that like I wasn't poor just
shows I was trying my ass off to book
shows and I wasn't booking and it it was
more reflection on how I felt about
myself it was like this giant mirror and
I yeah it made me more and more unhappy
until I realized that like wait them
booking shows doesn't mean that I have
to feel bad about my own lack of it you
know and that changed everything once I
started seeing it through that prism
when people would post about their
successes I was happy for them and
genuinely happy for them not just like
okay cool happy for you use a happy free
[ __ ] you know it was like a genuine
like yeah you can do it and I'll get
there to when the time's right you know
and I after that I was booking more
socially it can definitely be tough like
when you're single yeah it's funny too
because like I'll go back and I'll look
at pic
that I posted where I was like oh wait
we fought through that dinner and I'm
like posting that dinner photo like it
looks all cute and then I'm like that
was it's anywhere people especially
girls I think we talked about during JK
news where girls were going back to
their old Instagram posts and like RiRi
kept like read captioning like oh we
actually fought like he wasn't paying
attention to me he was on his phone half
the time like I guess I wasn't dressed
good enough to like catch his attention
yes so probably should have tried stitch
fix these ads are so funny how would you
describe your style in one word would it
be that simple
oh the words simple simple simple word
what about sophisticated oh I would love
that but I don't know where to start
adventurous are you Carrie are you
Miranda are you a Charlotte Charlotte
that sounds classy weight class well
maybe you can get some help when it
comes to shopping for clothes most of us
are amateurs I know I'm a bit of an
amateur when it comes to shopping you're
Samantha the professionals handle it
with stitch fix a stylist will do all
the work for you they're an online
personal styling service that will
deliver your favorite clothes shoes and
accessories directly to your door after
completing your style profile your
personal stylist will send a hand-picked
box of items based on your style and
preferences with no subscription
required you can pick between automatic
shipments or only getting new pieces on
demand so you're not gonna get trapped
in a constant thing if you don't want to
the styling fee is only 20 bucks and it
will be applied towards anything you
keep from your box doesn't it sound
pretty good guys that's done yeah si Mia
to get started today at stitch fix calm
slash mood and get an extra 25% off when
you keep everything in your box
that's it fit stitch fix calm slash mood
one more time stitch fix calm
stitch fix calm slash mood oh and also
not to mention that yo that the jewelry
I like the jewelry I'm so bad at picking
out jewelry they give you really nice
kind of dainty yeah that's my favorite
part
I've kept all of my jewelry and all the
jeans well with a great style you can
also bust out your phone from those new
jeans yeah what's your jeans yeah phone
out your G is the claim they said these
guys you know I'm obsessed with this
game she was playing this during lunch
yeah no no well there's 2000 levels
which one did you have girl I am on
level 327 I'm in the tower treetops
portion of the game and besides the fact
that they have really beautiful graphics
like I really really love this they
actually update the game every single
month and they have different events so
the game never gets alright I'm talking
smack cuz I downloaded it to you I did
it's actually really fun you get to in
the first couple of levels you to beat
up all the little slugs yeah and I just
got back on it the other day because
when they up when they updated the game
a little logo change again caught my eye
and I was like yeah like getting new
characters and the fact that you have to
use them yeah strategically to the next
little fiends they all have their little
special powers is really cool so it does
not require any internet so I play this
all the time when I'm flying like
traveling especially on those really
long flights and sometimes the plane
doesn't have internet I bust out my best
fiends game and I rack up those levels
so like I said I really really love it
engage your brain with fun puzzles and
collect tons of cute characters trust me
with over 100 million downloads this
five-star rated mobile puzzle game is a
must play download best fiends free on
the App Apple
Store or Google Play that's friends
without the are best fiends and let me
know what level you get on because I'm
in competition with all you guys like I
said only 43 when he said 30 so Niki
brought up a really interesting part a
point about like you know feeling like
you're missing something in a
relationship I think it's really
important sometimes for people to not
get consumed by that thing that they're
missing like yes you may feel like okay
I'm not in a relationship but you're not
in a love relationship with a partner
there's also family relationships
there's friends yeah there's career
there's do you have like a pet or
something like to what goals usual
spiritual there are there's a lot of
like there's so much like pressure to
just work to be in that one thing now
there's so much more to life than just
relationships and I think sometimes we
get consumed by that one chunk of the
puzzle we're missing you know it's the
most think that if you just had that
piece you'd be happy yeah and then you
forget yeah and you get so lost in that
that you forget about all of the other
pieces and I think that when you're
single something to remind yourself if
you get caught up in the thought of like
oh I'm single I wish I was in love what
are you doing with your career what are
you doing with your friendships are you
nourishing family are you setting goals
for the future
how are you setting yourself up so that
you're ready when that relationship does
come because it could come in right now
but then what if you're like okay great
now I have the relationship now I'll
work on my career now I'll work on my
friendships now we'll work or now I'll
work on my finances no fill all of those
voids before somebody comes into your
life so that you can keep them they also
say you get what you give so instead of
thinking like how do I get how do I get
get it yeah think about like what can I
give look like think of the thing you
want and try to give it and also I'm
gonna be honest because this is
something for myself if you have nothing
and you're looking for someone you will
attract somebody that also has nothing
yeah will sit there and suck each other
nothing and I can be sucked but
I mean I mean not truly because the
other thing is if you if you have you
know friendships and money you're not
gonna just you're you're not only not
gonna attract somebody that doesn't kind
of have those things in your life but
you're gonna have more side of my like
peace of mind what sort I'm looking for
more consciousness to be like yeah I
don't need this person yeah person has
nothing of value to add to my life but
when you're just looking for the
relationship you'll kind of just take
whatever comes at you mm-hmm
true yeah and that is not fair
relationships I feel like are the most
intoxicating and addicting part of our
lives
I guess so that's why it's easy to get
swept up in it there's this video that I
watched the other day and everyone has
their opinions on this guy but it's it
was Russell Brand video and he was
talking about because he's he's guy he's
such a weirdo but I loved it I loved his
mind I like the way he's always thinking
so like whether you agree with him or
not
is besides the point cuz he's always
thinking and I like that but he was just
talking about how when you make it's
it's almost like that biblical saying of
like worshipping a false idol and so I
think a lot of times we worship the
person that we were with or that we want
to have or like maybe there's a guy that
doesn't love you back or something and
we're worshiping them like a false idol
and that only can bring in suffering so
you have to really ground yourself
otherwise you're just gonna perpetuate
suffering so even if you do get that
relationship or you do get something
you're worshipping this false image of
them you think they're perfect you think
they're gonna fill your life and make it
whole it's only gonna wind up creating
suffering so you really have to ground
yourself and understand what the what a
purpose or relationship serves that's
what I'm going through right now is like
I always felt like I had to have someone
like the man was my false idol and
whatever [ __ ] he [ __ ] put me
through I just dealt with it because I
couldn't be alone and like I just went
through so much suffering unnecessarily
because I couldn't give up that
addiction to having a man there just any
man I think it's also something that
like society perpetuates especially with
quote saying all you need is love
[ __ ] you need to love your career
you need to love your mom you can love
your significant other and you
like it's not just I need a relationship
and so many movies and everything that's
the baseline of it like they don't show
Sally going out and getting her job
after she gets her man did Stella get a
job after she got her groove back like
there's so much margarine and it's
almost it's unhealthy look this is why
we're doing this show because we're here
to undo everything the society tire
brain [ __ ] your brain unfuck yourself no
no that was a good book - Oh Gary
something his audiobook whatever it's
not important anyway I'm [ __ ] yourself
it's called acting something like that
that's more Gary Biba unfuck your brain
Oh different guy what he's like Irish
all right you can google it by that much
information we're not sponsored by that
book so pay for that I'm sure you know
that dude our producer like he looked
Mike right up at it by the way everyone
our producer six-foot-four and single
girlfriend Bryce oh not take it he is on
the market we I I was just telling him
before this he was adjusting a camera
and he was like leaned over and then he
stood all the way up and I was like
Bryce is your room yeah it was anything
handyman yes he just be fixing [ __ ] we
were painting and like we could only
reach a certain height came along
it's turned into a date bright dancer
mom aunt stood up and I was like Brice
is your height in your tender play we're
gonna put his phone number as the top
comment text your nudes dachshund is a
message on at big mood girls on
Instagram if you're interested in dating
Brice will screen and reveal girls
within 40 miles of lost girls but love
yourself first make sure you have that
you can't date our dad mommy always
brings his new girlfriend to set every
Dame realizes she's gone the next week
we are ruining his sex life but yeah
like I think that activity is that you
just do for you are the things that you
learn like self esteem and like oh I can
bring myself that love and then when you
go into a relationship you're not
looking to get that from someone else I
kind of reminds me of when I was in high
school which was the only time other
than those two months in my life that I
have been single and I remember during
that time the happiest two months excuse
me ma'am it was like okay no yeah he was
the first one I was like ah one that I
actually really she looks happy get down
here with me [ __ ] so in high school I
remember
everyone around me being in
relationships yeah I'm like it was just
really hard to be especially in my
particular high school everyone was
having sex already and I was like 16 and
everyone was having sex and I'm like I
mean I'm a virgin let me get rid of his
virginity so I could be look at these
yeah so then I'm just aside all pressure
yeah there was so much and I remember
also when my girlfriend's they would be
in their relationships and they'd be
fighting and I'd be like I want that you
wanted the fight like I want I want
someone to like just yeah you within
like if it's gonna be fighting then okay
and so like I remember just really
yearning for a relationship and I don't
know if I could go back in time and talk
to that 16 year old TIFF I would just
tell her hey girl it's okay love
yourself by yourself find the time that
you kind of like so that you'll be like
we'll try this for six months no no no
cuz girl I don't deep dude is like first
one I'm like cool dude I did - I mean
like I get it if mine is my first
boyfriend I mean oh my god incredibly
abusive I told you about that that was a
long hug guy I wouldn't have left him I
would have never ever left him he broke
up with me my man did me a favor but
yeah I'd like that and another thing is
like there they might not always let you
go like it's hard to get out of a toxic
relationship to once you're in it
definitely especially when you you know
you think you've wanted this for so long
and you have a skewed perception of what
love is and and I also thought that like
arguing and fighting and relationships
is indicative of like oh this person
cares enough about me to fight with me
and yell about what yeah and now I'm
like oh my god no that's the complete
opposite of the truth the complete
opposite like if you're yelling at me
you don't actually care you're just an
[ __ ] like straight up yeah did you
guys like were you guys constantly in
relationships in high school I had a
relationship I think like my freshman
year and then I think I didn't until
yeah until I left into college I didn't
have my first boyfriend till I was 15
and then that was like for two years
which is like marriage in high school
and then I was single for the second
half of my senior year and that's when
that popular guy had dated me and like I
didn't know how to act and I was so
self-conscious and he ended up dumping
me and telling me everything that was
wrong with me oh I just remembered what
I did that made me break the cycle of
codependency I totally forgot about this
okay so I've I've had periods where I'm
not in a relationship but I've always
had a crush always never been a period
of time where I didn't have a crush and
if I did it was such a small fraction
that it just didn't it just didn't
register so you're mentally like
monogamous
yes mentally and I and like they would
always be big crushes and I just either
wouldn't pursue them or I would [ __ ] it
up and we didn't date so I had a friend
about 2 or 3 years ago that he went and
we weren't even that close at the time
but he was going through a breakup and
we got like close during it because I
just wanted to like help I don't know
like I felt like I kind of knew that he
just needed some feminine energy so I
just kind of like he lived with her she
was moving out they had been together
for like four years and so in this kind
of working with him through this breakup
I had he had an we just somehow had the
idea that neither of us would date
anybody for one year just not date
anyone for a single year 365 days we
could [ __ ] whoever we wanted like go out
and about but we just went in date and I
went into this pact with him it was
mostly for him but I went in on it with
him - and I took dating off of my radar
because I entered this pact and within 2
or 3 months I was over it I was
completely over I just decided I'm 25
I'm not gonna date for a year I'm gonna
have a blast and it worked and then when
I finally found this guy that I wanted
to be with um a little my old tendency
stayed but I also just was like I had my
horse blinders on and I was like all
right if it works out it works otherwise
I'm just gonna [ __ ] you and keep going
and then we ended up dating like six
months later like officially uhm but
yeah if you if you make a pact with
yourself just like I'm in my 20s I'm not
gonna date for a year you I think you
can if you're anything like me crazy um
you can kind of break that spell I think
yeah I find that I think I have that
pattern
- now that you mention it is like even
even in periods where I was single for
three years or something in between like
I was crushing on someone or kind of
pining for something and I never really
just had complete mental clarity
yeah you should I'm serious you should
try it is so fun to just date around
though but maybe I should like just say
I'm knocking it to a point yeah well I
mean if I keep [ __ ] guys though I'm
gonna like wind up getting attached so I
think maybe I should even if I don't do
it for a year but maybe if I try like
three months or six months without a sec
just to see if I can reach that level of
like complete mental clarity because
it's definitely like I'll still have a
crush on someone that I [ __ ] you know
four months ago and they're still
occupying a little bit of space so it's
almost like I'm still not completely
alone and I think yeah that's the thing
that I really want to get to is where
there's no one occupies my brain before
I get into my next relationship I think
when you kind of use that that little
method which I accidentally stumbled
upon it just takes it off your radar it
doesn't make it a factor because there
when you when you have that on your
radar you ask yourself mentally what are
we with you every single guy actually
hope that this is gonna lead somewhere
so it's like the crutch that gets you
through being single for a few months
it's like your environment comes back to
you and it's like but Jess you have to
be something yeah just [ __ ] buddies like
[ __ ] that create your own reality and
decide I'm not dating so I don't know
what they are I don't care but they're
not my boyfriend yeah and they're not my
husband and it just it created I almost
completely forgot about that but I think
it honestly changed my life yeah maybe
I'll try that and give it a shot and
then Jess will have to report back to us
in a few months when I did it but yeah
that about wraps up the episode for this
week guys thank you for listening thank
you for watching make sure you rate us
five stars on Apple podcast and also
don't forget you friends friends II love
I share this share this throw it on and
tell your boy you need to clean your
apartment and you need to listen to
these [ __ ] so come back on Thursdays
I think channel every day and refresh
the page at least twice a week come back
and check because we're having more than
more than once a week content yes oh yes
interactivity check it out before you
wreck it out wreck it out before you do
and also let us know too we want your
feedback what do you enjoy hearing about
do you like sex topics do you like a
little more self self-evaluation let us
know what your favorite episodes are to
date because I think we're coming up on
that time whether it's big mood or hey
[ __ ] let us know but we'll see you guys
next week